baby can keep your type and down trying
to make an ask IJ episode silly panda
bears question
the first YouTube question of a sky J
episode for peace love coexist wants to
know why do you dye your hair blonde
well let's see because this color
obviously didn't work this one either
definitely not this one either so I
guess you can say that's why this is
what I've got on the top of my head
right now okay with another youtube
comment Crispo sixteen asks what would
you look like as a brunette okay can we
just stop with all the hair questions
and what is this Bravo's sheer genius
her hair was as thick as 500 Eskimos
yeah I didn't think so
anyways I thought you guys would enjoy
this here's a picture of me from 2006
yes I was still doing photo shoots with
my Apple products yep I've always had a
problem so Lord GU asks if I can imagine
a life without internet connection
hmm Oh Lord to you that's funny that you
mention that I actually have time warner
cable's so I know exactly what that's
like
hi Justine Davis Rosie today look how
come you have two laptops and two foot
cameras and one yeah well the real
reason that I have two flips to laptops
is because I have a roommate yeah and
I'm a better editor than you quite
frankly I just don't like to share
especially not the panda bear that
doesn't even real
well that's it for ask i J episode make
sure you guys leave questions as
comments make video responses and ask me
questions on Twitter using this
Tomek and last but not least don't
forget to my other I just YouTube
channel where I can actually bench or
your post videos daily so check it out
see you guys the next